Angel, what keeps you out of me?
Baby, show me your love
Angel, show me your love
Girl, tell me, would you love me?
But it hurts me, love, love
Oh, my God
Baby, tell me, would you love me?
Hello, it's my little brother.
It's your brother? Oh shit, what's up?
This is Jose, big Jose.
What's your brother's name?
His name's John, and that's his girlfriend.
What's up, John? I heard you were hitting Fortnite emotes.
Yeah, you hitting a Fortnite emote for the camera?
See if I can get it, see if I can get it. Alright, go. Go, tell him to get it.
Tell camera man.
Come on!
Chop chop!
Oh, he's camera shy.
Let's go.
You got another shower, that's right.
You brought me your wife?
I remember Angela Marcos first.